okay so today we have ed McManus he was
a technical adviser for Silicon Valley
on HBO season three so ed what's your
background okay so I was a technical
co-founder of a Y Combinator startup
called yard sale and we launched two
products both were marketplaces for
iPhone so similar to Craigslist for
iPhone
the first product was called yard sale
and the second product was Fobo and we
sold the company in 2015 and yeah that's
back and somehow you became a technical
adviser accommodation oh yeah okay how'd
that happen
uh yeah I mean it was so weird I like it
felt a lot like luck so the the sort of
story here is you know we were cranking
hard on our startup for four years sold
it in 2015 in the acquisition it was
kind of mostly just to sort of do right
by our investors return as much as we
could but it was not like you know
phenomenal outcome for the company but
all of our investors had sort of like
been aware that we were sort of like
looking for our next thing and it just
just happened that randomly somewhere
from HBO reached out to Greylock who is
one of our investors and asked them the
question like hey we're trying to put
together sort of like this this team of
superstars from the tech world
who would go after and both me my
co-founder were on a list of names that
Greylock sent back okay
and yeah from there I think it was you
know just a matter of being available it
was vaguely an employee sort of funny um
and I mean it was it was kind of a crazy
story because they sent us an email and
I've been a huge fan of the show for a
really long time and as soon as we got
that it just like was apparent to me
this is a drop everything and make this
happen kind of opportunity so
they flew us in for an interview it was
kind of weird because it actually wasn't
really an interview it was just like our
first day at work really we didn't know
this right so and your hook on over
there so we actually went on separate
days but we both had a similar kind of
experience
I flew in and I grabbed lunch with with
the one of the other technical advisors
from the show and he's like okay you're
all set for your interview so he drove
me over to the studio lot dropped me off
and I showed up at the the Silicon
Valley office and I you know told them I
came here for the interview and no one
knew what I was talking about okay so I
told them who I was and they're like
okay I think I think we know where
you're supposed to go and so they lead
me into the writers room and everyone's
in there so like the whole writing
production is on yeah the writing is on
right I see Mike judge in the corner and
it's just this like weird surreal kind
of like I know who you are you have no
idea who I am like you know anytime you
encounter someone that you consider to
be a celebrity and I it turns out that
it was just like no one had told them
either that I was showing up to
interview so it's just like they just
gave me a seat and I listened for like
three and four hours three or four hours
and just like gave input wherever I
could okay
and you know it turned out that most of
the job is actually just sort of like
sitting and listening and it's very rare
that you actually have to speak up and
sort of like help them course-correct
but occasionally they would ask a
question sort of like you know can you
walk us through the fundraising process
given like the company's at like a seed
stage yeah you know I'd provide some
color there around that and so your
first day ends and like you just leave
you just go home so I just I just walk
out yeah I flew back up to San Francisco
I got a call that night and they said
locate that it went it went great like
we'd like for you to join and they
wanted me to start that Monday this is
on a Friday that I enter of course so I
had one weekend to sell everything so I
just like had a sidewalk sale I got one
of my friends to help me out and like
sold about 80% of
that I owned just like really commit to
this and I drove down to Los Angeles on
Sunday night I got in at like 3:00 in
the morning or something on Monday and
had to show up at nine o'clock the next
morning okay
for like my first full day of work okay
so like just drop us into the context
what's happening in the show at the
beginning of season three yeah so at
this point I think like the first maybe
two episodes had been written it was
still very early in the development of
the season but they had outlines maybe
for like the first five or so episodes I
think beyond that it was kind of like no
one really knew where they where the
season was going to go okay um so yeah
when I showed up I mean it was like I
was just trying to find my footing like
it's just very like to be honest it was
hard it was really hard because I've
never done anything in entertainment
I've never worked with people like this
before everyone there was just like
off-the-charts brilliant hmm
were they technical at all so almost
everyone in the room had a very solid
understanding of how startups were not
technical though in the sense it like
they couldn't you know write code but
one of the things I was surprised by was
how well the writers sort of understood
Silicon Valley and just a material they
were covering I mean sort of like a
common theme of my time in the show was
actually that like I didn't have to do a
whole lot of corrections okay they kind
of got it so um before every season they
actually come up to San Francisco for I
think like a week or two weeks and meet
with a bunch of startup so they like
every writer goes through this kind of
like in a crash course so to get up to
speed and so by the time that they
actually start working on the season
they have like a pretty good
understanding of sort of how you know
how things work and what what life in
startups is actually like and so then
given that like where do you find
yourself providing value every day of
the show yeah so for the most part it
was you know like like I said it was
kind of um the job was explained to me
like it's almost like being a lifeguard
right so like you kind of sit on the
sidelines for a bit when you see
something going wrong that's when you
like you
actually I say something so you know I
was on him to answer any questions and
that kind of stuff but at the same time
I wanted to recognize it I'm not like a
comedy person like that is that could
not be further from my skill set so I
tried to kind of like not like pitch
jokes or do anything like that
like I just recognize that that's not
you know that's that's not what I'm good
at
so instead I was thinking through sort
of like the technical details it's for
like the strategy like even where the
company was at that point in time like
what are the kinds of things that
they're going to try and do and so where
were their points where you felt that
like they were going off course and you
had to correct it yeah I mean there
definitely were times where that would
happen but like nothing nothing major
right like I don't think there were no
there were no like like like huge course
corrections as a result of my in pipe um
there were definitely some some some you
know like like tweaks here and there but
for the most part it's the writers want
to do something we could find sort of a
technical explanation to justify okay
I'm doing that right and like I mean
that's kind of true like I feel like
that's not super surprising right like
these guys are you know fantastic
programmers supposedly they can do
whatever they want like we can we can
find a justification for almost any kind
of like story point so the way it would
work if they would they would come up
with a script and we would so they did
sorry that the first step of the process
was to sort of come up with these
outlines and from there like get handed
off to a single writer who would go off
and turn it into an actual script and
they would more or less leave blank
spots okay yeah and so the bulk of my
job at first was just kind of like
filling in the blanks okay yeah it was
just yeah and it's like I thought that
that was going to be easy but it's
actually it's it's fairly bland it's
it's not super easy because like you
have to come up with a dialogue that
it's like okay you have two lines to
explain sort of the technical
tales of what's going on here you can't
get into the technical detail so you
have to like keep it like very like like
fairly vague right and that was that was
tough I mean you can't get into the
details because folks are essentially
like they're not going to understand or
you don't have enough like words to fit
in or I mean it's a combination of both
right even if we could dedicate 30
minutes to like just the technical I
talking about depression oh no no that's
not why people like are interested in
this show so you know like the tech is
there to serve the story it's like you
know and I think that's that's a right
way to do it like the technical details
like another five years or not going to
be super important I like the stuff that
people are going to relate to it's you
know it's like that it's the characters
it's sort of like their own motivations
like the emotions that kind of stuff and
so what examples did you fill in for
like what gaps did you have to fill uh I
mean anytime like one of the characters
says anything technical that was
something that that was it that either I
wrote or or reviewed so for example if
it was something relating to compression
sometimes like if it were something that
were really specific to an expertise
like I'm not a compression guy but but
we have folks who are working with the
show who who are so in that case we
would send it out to them
get their feedback and then sort of like
try and bring everything together to
make it work for this you okay and so
then like going back then can you talk a
little bit about the entire premise of
Pied Piper like is that possible is the
compression algorithm they tried to do
at the end of season one a thing like
what's the deal with that surprisingly
yes all right so when I okay so there
there's a couple of pieces here but like
one is that when I first showed up I was
like this technology is too good right
right like if this were a real thing
Pied Piper would never fail like there's
a notion right like they could not fail
into the challenges like how do you like
make them fail like at the end of every
episode inside you know every episode
arc is kind of like things look great
it's kind of like the we actually it's
almost like the anti entourage right
like that like how some of them are
thinking about the show we're like
entourage
as things like start off horrible and
then by the end of the episode they're
fantastic right Silicon Valley the
opposite yeah Silicon Valley is like
things seem like they're going so great
like Aaron's like contract being a
billionaire and by the empty episode
like never the sky is falling so um the
challenge was to take this technology
that's like a like can't lose and like
turn it into something that like you
know like they keep stumbling over so so
that was really tricky and then what was
the oh the algorithm at the end of
season one yeah the the surprising thing
with middle-out is that like there is
actually a technical background for it
and and like like it is actually the
result of a lot of sort of machine
learning development applied to
compression so the sort of like the
theory behind the tech like is actually
like it's plausible like this is it this
is a piece of software that could exist
most likely would not have the same kind
of like characteristics that middle-out
does in the show it's great for
screaming its lossless like it has like
all these performance characteristics
which are like very difficult to achieve
in the real world okay so like if this
thing existed in the real world would be
like no question absolute breakthrough
but wait why wouldn't it exist what are
the issues there just because well it
would just be a scientific breakthrough
for something like like mid allowed to
exist okay gotcha that's what it comes
down to okay gotcha so one of the things
that I was wondering is like oftentimes
we find at least around YC that you know
like Google or hooli isn't going to
immediately replicate whatever you're
working on do you ever bring that up
that like the startup versus giant
company thing is like maybe not the most
common thing in Silicon Valley it does
happen right and I think it happened
more in the past so a lot of the
knowledge of the team is drawing on it's
actually kind of from the dot-com boom
money you know like in the 90s so
imagine who is actually Microsoft right
Microsoft was like they
and threat if Microsoft said they were
coming after your market like watch out
right so maybe a better comparison today
would be like Facebook right Google like
we we all kind of like have like all of
my experiences with Google being sort of
the dominant company those guys are like
just so nice like it like look like that
that's something that's new right like
yeah that didn't used to be the case um
so so now I think it's it's kind of like
plausible that we can say like oh the
big companies not going to go after you
know like this small startup but like I
think that's a new thing and maybe not
can be the case for much longer like you
know like the Facebook for example is
getting a little bit more aggressive
going after a smaller spaces and so yeah
I think that that that is like a
legitimate concern okay fair enough
I mean it sets up a story well and yeah
Eve nothing else and it's good for yeah
it's good for driving the story forward
okay were there any em were there
anything left on the cutting-room floor
that you were really excited about that
just got pulled pulled from the show so
uh yeah actually there were I think like
one or two episodes at the end of the
season
so like episode I think like like I want
to see episode 9 or something where the
plan was actually to go to FMR aisle
so if Emer aisle is kind of like Burning
Man in the Delta here in Northern
California yeah I was on a boat that
sank there and like it sounded like it
was going to be incredible and that
actually got caught more for production
reasons than for you know for technical
reasons but that left the the show at
this hole in the season and so there was
like this mad dash at the end of that
sort of writing writing period to fill
it in with like that like two or three
new episodes which is like which is like
incredibly difficult so what-what
episodes were those so I like the luau
thing or yeah it starts there I think I
think the the luau is maybe like Episode
seven or something I but it was all
around me the beta launch and so like
what we were left with is this like this
whole of a couple of episodes at the end
of this season
and like the challenges like okay so
what or kind of screwed here right like
like what can we do and like I feel like
if I pointed to any episodes that I sort
of like added the most to it would be
those three okay um they ended up
pulling directly from our experience
with with yardsale launching a beta and
sort of like not being totally sure at
first like whether this thing is working
or not and getting a really strong like
positive signal early and then you know
like four six months in you're looking
at the numbers and you're thinking like
maybe this thing's not not as strong as
we thought yeah and were you guys so if
I remember correctly that's also when
the numbers are being faked right so
that yeah that happened a little bit
more towards the end Oh like things were
getting so dire you know they were about
to run out of money that's like they go
off and start taking some of them oh and
that originally was going to be sort of
a plot around growth hacking and then it
like just like edged its way into fraud
but there was like this whole
fascination around growth hacking and
buying users and that kind of stuff and
of course like when you take yourself
back to five years ago in the startup
world for four or five years ago like
growth hacking was like like this new
hot thing like it seemed like a
legitimate way to sort of like get your
product to product market fit
um so it was like super alluring and
then it kind of like entered this kind
of like this grey hat world and just got
gradually worse and worse so great yeah
and so the show ended up being kind of
like a reflection of like sort of like
where that was where that was going
because I'm like yeah there's definitely
legitimate in sort of like bad yeah I
can't like grow tactic right and then
were there moments like you know you
when you think about like growth hacking
in the industry or whatever they're
often like prominent figures were you
ever asked to like put someone on the
spot and it like felt like too
on-the-nose
like making fun of them directly or is
that just kind of like all fair yeah we
have a reference to their nose in the
show but that was kind of like you know
if so it was like very common knowledge
at that point I think that that like we
the show would not go after anyone
unless it were sort of like already kind
of like a big story yeah a lot of what
the writers end up using is you know
stuff that gets pulled from the
headlines really it's you know like real
stories that they just sort of like
reshape to to kind of fit the situation
as the Pied Piper geysering because
that's what I always wondered right like
it always feels like not to say that
it's like basic but it is like popular
culture so it can value right and so
we're there moments where you were
trying to like push it to be like more
like ephemeral Isle is actually a really
good example but we're there other like
more like fringe things people were
trying to put in that folks would be
like I don't know about this and then
take it out if anything I I wanted more
of that stuff in this yeah so like one
of the I remember watching like season
one and season two and thinking like why
are these guys building you know like
their own servers it doesn't make sense
no way no the world does this right in
it felt really inauthentic smiiing so if
like you know season three comes around
I'm like finally in the decision to do
something about this one of the things
that like I was you know like I was like
we have to get the guys to move to AWS
okay at the very least right like I
think that like if we could have gotten
them to Heroku that would have been even
better great anybody but but there was a
like the audience for Silicon Valley's
interesting right because it's not all
started but there are a lot of technical
people who are sort of like really in
like into it and so like a lot of the
technical folks who watch they're not
there they're like maybe sort of like
not on like that you know like the
bleeding edge of kind of like trends
that are like you know catching out on
the startup world for startups like if
you're not building on AWS like really
behind it doesn't make sense yeah I you
know in in so watching the show is
someone could like actually done it
startup like that was something that
didn't sit well with me though so it
would like I yeah got them to to move to
AWS had to make a case for that
and like we expected a lot of pushback
from black developers watching the show
saying like Oh like you know you should
like they would never remove the AWS
like they want control over their own
servers like whatever the this
complaints might be hi it it was fine I
think like no no one really complained -
like the timing ended up being being
good that's so what about like all those
other elements where like the show
touches the real world right so like you
know you we talked before we were
starting the interview about you doing
like things that were like Oscar
on-screen elements that weren't writing
like when do those things come into play
and like where did what did you work on
in particular yeah I mean so if you
watch any episode just pay attention to
stuff in the background because like the
show is designed to be possible like
like you can freeze frame anything and
like look at the documents for example
in their hands or like the whiteboards
in the background okay all of that stuff
who is like me and or like you know some
of the other consultants working on that
just like writing on post-it notes um
yeah right exactly like the the the
scrum board is a good example of that
like every post it has something that
you know like we had to like sit down
spend time thinking about and yeah I
mean I like I both love and hate the
process of making those whiteboards
there were times where like walking the
cache through sort of like like a booth
there's one scene in particular during
the feedback they use our feedback
session where Richard gets up and starts
drawing some stuff on a whiteboard so
like I had to sort of walk in through
each of those pieces of like okay this
is what this you know this graphic here
means and like that kind of stuff and
that was awesome there was another time
where we had some code displayed on a
projector in like I got to walk Mike
through like what this code actually did
I think in the second episode we hid an
easter egg in some C code okay that we
like had just sort of like like flash on
screen for like a second okay and people
are pausing it yeah exactly
pausing it copying it over and actually
compiling it and it was kind of cool I
wrote like a
simple compression algorithm okay like
it's hard to even call it a compression
algorithm but like I took this this
character string and you could you could
decompress it expand it into a larger
string which just got printed to the
console okay I can't remember what
message we settled on but but someone
ran out yeah yeah like it ended up being
a big post on Reddit but amazing it was
just like those attention that attention
to detail was that code online anywhere
like were you guys on github giving all
that stuff or yeah it's online now it
wasn't it wasn't originally okay and so
the show is not done a ton of like
crossover into the real world
last season we had this character Winnie
and I actually I created a github
profile for playback purposes right so
just like we wanted not entik looking
github profile the best way to do that
it's just to make it get that profile
for that person so so I made one for
Winnie and we had to populate it both
with the fake commit history and also
with like projects that you know she
would have pushed to so set all this up
got the the screenshots and the playback
finished then I forgot to delete the
account and so as soon as it aired
people were you know like a searching on
github for this for this character is
username she showed up in so it ended up
going by wrong on reddit again I was
just like instantly flooded with with
poor requests and like it was a really
kind of awesome experience and it was
like one of the first times that the
show like really crossed into the real
world in like an authentic way because
it was accidental yeah but it was it was
very cool to see were there ever any
moments where you were actually thinking
about like building some kind of
software thing that would like overlap
or was that just never never crossing
the mind there no yeah there there uh
there's one idea in particular I was
working on an audio project at the time
and realized it's like we could pretty
easily sort of encode like text in an
audio file and so one of the pitches in
the writers room was actually to have a
character who would sort of like play a
little clip
for like you know some some fantasy app
that he was working on and anyone with
the corresponding app could actually
sort of decode the audio it would be
like you know secret message that we
could send out yet exactly a little
Easter Egg that we could send that to
all the viewers that's amazing and then
what about the people like being
introduced in the show the other
characters like do you as startup guy
for the show like are you trying to like
pull out those characters to throw them
in or do they never even ask you for
that kind of thing all of that like like
very little of that comes out of like a
technical need yeah so it's almost
exclusively just for you know story
purposes of like like moving things
forward and so you know there's an
opportunity to provide some input and
say like well this is what that person
might work on yeah and that would be a
good example of like a blank left in the
script
right so like someone's title into like
even even small things like that which
are not necessarily like it's not code
right like it's not it's not like like
related to programming but it is a
technical detail and so like you can
give them a title for example that's
kind of like tailored to the startup
world okay in so that was you know like
that's a that's a good example of the
kind of thing day right okay but you
don't have to like predict the future
and like bring people in and okay that
makes sense so I know this is like a
very obscure kind of job but if someone
who is in the startup world wanted to
get into it how would they get into it
and then how do they get good at it it's
yeah it's it's a tough one to answer
right because like this isn't a real job
like they don't exist in the way that
like you can't apply to be like a
technical consultant really like you'd
kind of like you walk into it a little
bit and there are I guess I can think of
three different routes like to sort of
like get into a position like this the
first two are what not very reliable the
first it's just like you kind of be
someone in my position who just like
worked really hard at startups right um
and like and never thought that this
would lead to sort of like it something
in entertainment like in the
entertainment world but you know it did
the second is to be an expert in like
some specific field which like also like
you later
at no point but we be doing that so that
you can get you know like to work on a
show the third I think is kind of like
the best route and that's to work it
like an agency or some kind of
organization that also works with
production companies and the the guy who
brought me on board Jonathan Doulton who
is sort of like that the main consultant
for the first two seasons that would
kind of paved paths in and for that you
know like you can just be on the lookout
for promising script and then try and
jump on them when you can in the benefit
of that is that you get in early and you
know you can you can stick with the show
for for a long time
are you dabbling with other shows at
this point you know no I mean it was
like a real big I have a hard time
figuring out whether or not this is
something I wanted to continue doing
he's like on the one hand it was an
incredible experience on the other I
know that my my sort of like position is
up here in San Francisco like working on
startups like it's doing actual start-up
stuff know sort of like they pretend
yeah exactly
and so after after this class season I
just call like I'd like I needed to come
back like um uh yeah I don't know like
it was definitely I was I was kind of
50/50 on it for a while but just felt
like you know like I had given them all
my stories like if I went back for
another season I'd be like I don't know
what to tell you it uh you haven't
worked on a video chat app right right
okay yeah so who do who do you think is
doing this particularly well like what
other shows are like really technical
and in an interesting way that's like
somewhat plausible right there's a
couple of show so as there's two shows
and watching right now that I'm like
obsessed with yeah one is mr. robot and
even when I was on
looking valia can I sit like this is the
gold standard for both playback and
technical accuracy they really nailed it
so like you know the technical details
are sound sort of like the technical
story actually plays a pretty big role
in the show as a whole and yeah
everything about it feels it feels good
the second film watching this Holden
catch fire right huh which I actually
just started watching like a month ago
it's fantastic it's like it's so good
and the thing is it like it takes place
in the early 80s so you know the tech
that they're talking about it's not
something I'm familiar with and I
imagine that like like there's like only
couple dozen people in the world who
like really will pay attention tender
well show at the same time right yeah so
you know maybe like in some sense like
that it's almost like an easier job but
yeah those two shows in particular I
think are really great
every new show that comes out on the
scene though is like has a really high
bar yeah so you know I don't know if
Silicon Valley is just kind of like
leading the way here but it seems to be
like a real strong trend that especially
it's like production budgets go up
another big big thing is that like a
season orders are going down right so
like now instead of like producing 20
episodes a season they're only doing ten
which just means the quality of every
episode is so high that they can you
know afford to take the time to reach
out to the consultants they need to like
really get the details right yeah I'm
curious to see if like you know given
Amazon and Netflix spending so like
billions of dollars on new programming
if they're just going to throw a ton of
technical people into it like even
though science fiction shows like
because it seems like it's tremendous
value add and there's so many nerds to
like woman who has it like you excited
about working in comedy or anything or
doing comedy so I felt like a part of my
brain was getting exercise that like had
just you know like been dormant for like
the six years of like doing a start-up
so like it was it was it was great
I I don't know if like I do not think I
have a career of comedy ahead of me like
definitely not uh but like that it was
stole yeah just a incredible experience
that's awesome David okay so what's next
for you I don't know and I start up I
think it's like it ended up being a
really cathartic experience working on
the show and I the last three episodes
of season three were like such a bummer
like there's one team where like Richard
is just lying the bathtub and it seems
like everything's gone wrong and like I
remember really associating with that
and just thinking like oh man like I've
been in that I've been in that place
yeah you know I so there was there were
definite like like a year or two years
were like after doing my startup like
you know I didn't want to write code
again and this is like this is like one
step in the process for sort of like
getting getting back into it um and yeah
now I'm you know pretty pretty stoked to
jump into something again feel energized
and and rested so alright well the last
question then is like why is YC not in
Silicon Valley
yeah that's a question that I asked the
writers and I started to realize it like
it was kind of on the radar but they
didn't really understand the
significance of Y Combinator in Silicon
Valley
oh right flank fully and like as soon as
I started realizing this I kind of like
backed off a little bit he's like if Y
Combinator in hacker news specifically
they look how knows a huge surprise
right yeah hacker news is like never
mentioned and I like I brought this up
it at one point in real it was like just
barely on the radar I felt like maybe I
shouldn't push this iterative because it
was kind of a secret like you know if
you know like you but that was
definitely something that you know I've
thought a lot about hack renews is like
like the place to go why do i CV place
to go if you're doing a start-up so like
yeah well we may have just added
ourselves I know so if don't don't be
shocked at that and then shows up in the
next season
okay laughter you're great
you